learning in general games
this talk is going to have two parts uh
the first part i'll discuss a couple of
papers that get near optimal rates to
knowing about learning in finite games
this is based off of two papers
and in the second part i'll discuss how
we can extend some of these results to
the setting of infinite or more
generally non-parametric gains
i'm a result in this talk are based off
of joint work with many great co-authors
nowadays modern machine learning
applications are multi-agent in nature
consider for instance generative
adversarial networks where you have a
discriminator and a generator competing
against each other with the goal of
attempting to generate images from some
natural distribution
there's multi-agent reinforcement
learning where multiple agents compete
with each other each trying to optimize
their own reward function
and there's also adversarial examples
where on the one hand there's a
classifier attempting to correctly
classify images
there's an adversary that attempts to
corrupt the output of the classifier
now we have a lot of successful
approaches both in theory and in
practice
for single agent machine learning
but when we try to extend these the
multi-agent settings
often they break completely or they
become at least more unstable or brittle
and so an important question is what
needs to change in our approaches for
single agent learning to achieve
comparable success in the multi-agent
setting
to begin to address this question i'm
going to consider a really simple
multi-agent setting which is finite
normal form games
so we can consider the repeated game
setting so agents play a general sum
game repeatedly over a finite time
horizon
this can be used to model many real-life
applications such as auctions repeated
bidding at auctions or playing in
network routing games
an important question in this setting is
how do we model agent strategies over
time
so one idea is to assume that agents can
compute a nash equilibrium up front and
then play according to the nash
equilibrium at each of many time steps
unfortunately this hypothesis is first
of all problematic because it's
computationally hard to compete to
compute a nash equilibrium even in
finite normal form games
and it's also not supported by some
empirical evidence which indicates that
agents often don't play according to
nash equilibrium
the second hypothesis that we'll
consider is to assume that agents update
their strategies
over time according to some simple
online learning
algorithms when we do this the most
fundamental and important question is
does this algorithm converge to
equilibrium and if so how fast
so i'm going to give a little bit of
background online learning in games
dates back well over half a century to
brown's work on fictitious play black
low approachability a non-consistency
and many other works
and one of the most desirable properties
of an online learning algorithm is that
it be no
regret so we say that an algorithm is no
regret
if each player's regret
or the difference between their
cumulative loss and the best possible
loss they could have achieved in
hindsight
is sub linear in the horizon t the
number of time steps t
and there's many popular no regret
learning algorithms that have been well
studied over the years
some of them are listed here
but first of all why do we care about
regret
well first of all it's a very natural
notion
but second it has a nice uh property
involving equilibrium converges to
equilibrium
if an algorithm has regret at most some
function epsilon of t
then the empirical averages of the
algorithms joint action profiles over
time when all ages play according to
algorithm in a game
converges to a type of equilibrium known
as coarse correlated equilibrium and a
rate of epsilon of t over t
now for those of you who are unfamiliar
this is a
superset of nash equilibria but unlike
nash it's computationally feasible to
compute them
and what's nice is that all of these now
we've got learning algorithms have
regret that grows on the square root
the order of square root of the horizon
t
so that means that gives convergence to
course correlated equilibrium at a rate
of one over root t
and this this this rate of root t is
known to be optimal against the worst
case adversary
but there's an important thing to note
here
which is that in games agents are not
facing worst case adversaries they're
facing other copies of
their own algorithm playing against them
so the question that we're going to
address in this talk is can this worst
case adversarial regret of rootsy
be improved if we use that all eight
agents in the game are playing according
to a no regret learning algorithm
and the answer to this question uh is
yes
but to explain exactly what the results
are i need to first formally introduce
our model
we work in the following setting we
assume that there's m strategic agents
you can think of these as for instance
bidders in an advertising auction and
each agent i has a finite action set a i
the product of this agent's action sets
is a which is the
a1 times a2 all the way up to am
that's the joint action set
and each agent i has a loss function
which is a mapping from the joint action
set to a real number between zero and
one given agent i's loss
if all agents play according to some
given joint action profile
here's the setting we consider for each
time step t
each agent i choose the strategy s i t
which is a distribution over their
actions but think of this as a vector
lying in the simplex distributions over
ai
and the collection of strategies s t
which is the concatenation of the
individual vectors s one t three s m t
determines a loss vector for each agent
i
the number of uh element entries in this
loss vector is the number of actions
the ai entry of lit
is simply the expected loss of agent i
if they play according to the action ai
and others draw their
actions from the distribution st
so here's the same thing written out in
notation we're just looking at
expectation over this distribution of
agent i's loss function
now finally each agent i suffers a loss
which is the expected value of the loss
function over the distribution st and
this can be seen easily to be equal to
the inner product of their strategy
vector s i t and the loss vector l i t
after suffering this loss the age and i
observe the loss vector which tells them
how to improve their loss
improve their strategy in future
iterations
so this is basically from agent i's
perspective equivalent to the setting of
online linear optimization
with full information feedback
each agent i's goal is to minimize the
regret
which is the difference between two
terms is the aggregate loss of the
algorithm that they're playing
and the best possible loss in hindsight
they could have achieved by playing a
single fixed action in their action set
and of the many no regret algorithms i
mentioned a couple slides ago a
particularly important one is hedge
otherwise known as exponential weights
it's a very simple algorithm the up the
iterates are shown here
so in the first round agent i plays a
uniformly random action from their
action set
and in the subsequent rounds each agent
i updates their strategy vector
according to the formula shown here
in particular
you to get the strategy record time t
plus one you take that at time t
and you re-weight it according to an
exponential of minus the step size eta
times the loss
at time t for each action
now this is a very natural formula
because actions with higher loss are
going to be down weighted by a larger
amount in subsequent iterations
and the regret of hedge is known to
against the worst case adversary scale
is a constant times the square root of t
times log number of actions
this regret bound is tight against an
adversarial loss that's a well-known
result
but it turns out that it's also tight in
the game
setting in particular chen and pang
showed that
in the game setting regret can scale
as a constant times the square root of t
when all agents use hedge
this is a somewhat disappointing result
because we want to be able to improve
these roots you regret bounds in games
the good news though is that there's a
slight modification of hedge known as
optimistic edge
which can get better equip bounds so how
does it differ from hedge
it only differs in this re-weighting
term previously we had the term shown
here
but an optimistic hedge we have an
additional thing we're adding on which
is the loss vector at time t minus the
loss at time t minus one
and this additional component of the
optimistic hedge update rule can be
thought as a sort of prediction of the
losses at time t plus 1.
it turns out that what you can show
fairly generically is that if the losses
that optimistic hedge encounters are
predictable in the sense that it
achieves improved regret bounds over
those of hedge
and a lot of the work about showing
optimistic hedge gets better rates than
games is showing that in some sense the
loss vectors are indeed predictable
now optimistic hedge also gets this same
worst case adversary that we grab down
his hedge
um against against an adversary but as
i've said
this can be improved in games
okay so how exactly uh how much can this
endowment improve by if all agencies
optimistic edge here's our main result
so for simplicity and stating things i'm
going to assume that each player has the
same number of actions
and so the carnality of the joint action
set is the carnality of individual
agents action set to the end of power
what we show is that if agents with
joint action set a
play a general sum game over t rounds
each player uses optimistic hedge to
update their strategy
then the regret of each player is a
constant times logarithm the number of
actions times log of t to the fourth
now ours is not the first result that
gets fast rates for learning games to
kind of explain the context i'll i'll
briefly overview some prior work on this
problem
so after the
you know in addition to the worst case
regret of rootsy
um it's been known for over a decade
that in the two-player zero-sum game
setting
there are several specialized algorithms
which can get poly logged with nick
regret and t and the number of actions
now two players zero sum games there are
many respects much easier than general
sun gains one important respect in which
they're easier is that optimistic
algorithms such as optimistic hedge
actually exhibit last iterate
convergence to the nash equilibrium
and this last unit convergence makes it
in a rough sense easier to prove faster
rates
and correspondingly the
fast rates that have been known in
multiplayer general some games have
lagged behind those in two-player
zero-sum games so in 2012 in 2015 uh
sergey sadell showed regret on the
scales is t to the minus one fourth
ah that was improved to t to the one
sixth
by chen and peng in 2020
and our result was the first to get a
poly logarithmically graphed down in t
for multiplayer general sum games
and subsequent to our work uh there's
been
a new paper which shows that a different
algorithm called clairvoyant mw
gets regret that's constant of the time
horizon t
although they work in a slightly
different setting of multiplayer general
sum games but with free with free rounds
of computation
okay so now we have one uh slide
overviewing the proof of our main
theorem
there's two main lemmas in the proof of
our main theorem the first is shown here
it gets what's known as a path length
regret bound um
against an adversary so what we show is
that for an adversarial sequence of
losses
agent i's regret
is bounded above by the sum of three
terms
the first term is relatively mild is
just log of number of actions over step
size
the second term is the sum
of each time step t of the difference
between loss vectors and consecutive
rounds
measured with respect to a particular
local norm
and the local normally used here is uh
you know mentioned on top of the slide
you don't have to worry about it it's
not that important for the purposes of
this slide
there's a third term which is negative
so it's going to help us make the egret
bound smaller
it's a sum over time step state of the
loss vector at time step t measure it
again with respect to this local norm
this lemma is relatively standard it's
similar things to it have been known for
a while
we do have to modify the existing work a
little bit but that's not the build of
the proof the bulk of the proof is
actually the second lemma
which shows basically that the sum of
the blue terms in lemma 1 are bounded
above by the sum of the red terms
and combining these two lemons gives a
poly logarithmic bound almost
immediately because lemma 2 says we can
replace the second two terms of lemma
one with basically something that's
polylogarin they can see and that gets
what we want to assuming the step size
is chosen appropriately
so limit 2 is the bulk of the proof i'll
give you a little bit of intuition as to
why it holds
we want to show the blue terms are small
now this actually has precedent in the
literature so again i said i'll show
that the blue terms are small in an
absolute sense in particular i showed if
the step size is chosen small enough
then the blue terms will be small in
comparison to that step size
of course we can't make the step size
too small because of this first term in
limit one
and to show them two we really have to
show that the blue terms are small in a
relative sense
but this isn't obvious you know what if
the blue terms are small but the red
terms are even smaller
so let's work through this a little bit
what happens if some loss vector l i t
minus 1 is small compared to the blue
term at the same time step
well suppose that we can show that the
difference is the loss factors these
blue terms themselves change slowly as a
function of time
it turns out that eventually the red
terms will become large
so in particular say loss vector l1 is
is uh quite small
we have some arbitrary difference of
loss vectors which gives some gloss
vector li 2 which might be a little bit
larger
but if the blue terms don't change that
much we're kind of adding roughly the
same direction to these vectors over
time
because we're adding roughly the same
direction the loss vectors themselves
the red terms will eventually become
large
and that's good because that basically
allows us to show something like limits
okay so now i'll uh that's that's kind
of the idea of the proof on that we'll
discuss some extensions of our main
results
uh so here's one extension
recall that our main theorem
gets a bound on the regret of each agent
this is otherwise known as external
regress
and it's nice because it complies
convergence to a type of equilibrium
known as coarse correlated equilibrium
now there's a more fine gradient notion
of equilibrium known as correlated
equilibrium which also contains almost
and it's computationally feasible to
compute unfortunately we graph bounds
are not enough to get convergence to
correlated equilibrium
we need convergence of a stronger notion
of regret known as the swap regress
i've defined swap regret here
roughly speaking it's similar to regret
but the comparative term shown in blue
is a little bit different
we're now taking a minimum over all
uh
functions pi from the action set of a i
to itself
i'm going to call such a function a swap
function
look at the aggregate loss in all t
rounds
of
the following
consider
any round where agent i plays any action
a
we're going to consider the loss of that
agent if instead they played action pi
of a
in that same round and we do this for
all rounds and all actions
and taking the minimum over all possible
swap functions where they swap from one
action to another
gives us this blue comparative term
and that that defines the swap regress
the floppy grid is enough to get
convergence to correlate at equilibrium
and we can show a corollary or sorry we
can show an extension of our main
theorem that holds for swapping
so
joint work with you know several
co-authors we've shown that if each of
many players uses a no swap regret
algorithm in particular a particular
algorithm by stoltz and lugosi combined
with optimistic hedge in a certain way
then each player i gets swap regret that
scales as the number of players times
the number of actions times log of t to
the fourth
now there's another no swapping
algorithm literature by blum and monster
and a similar result holds for their
snow swapping good algorithm combined
with optimistic hedge albeit with a
slightly worse polynomial dependence in
the number of actions
and it's an interesting open question as
to whether or not this linear dependence
the number of actions can be improved
for every result results on regret or
external regret we're able to get
logarithmic dependence in the number of
actions
linear is known or polynomial is known
to be necessary
in the adversarial setting we don't know
if that's the case in the game setting
so that concludes the first part of the
talk
in the second part i'll move on to
discuss how we can get fast rates for
regret
in infinite games or non-parametric
games
and to motivate this i'm going to go
back to the
the
some of the questions i discussed in the
first slide
there's many challenging non-convex
multi-agent settings such as multi-agent
reinforcement learning
learning and generative adversarial
networks
and these of course are not finite
normal form games
they can be expressed as infinite normal
form games but you take the space of
actions ai of each agent to be say the
space of all weights
of a neural network
and this is a pretty daunting thing to
do it's kind of hard to work with uh
instead of always the neural network by
using optimistic hedge over them the way
that we did in the first part of the
talk
so what prior work has done in terms of
equilibrium computation in such settings
is to for instance look for local
notions of equilibrium
unfortunately there's many
intractability or non-existence results
so one type of equality known as pure
strategy local nash equilibria may not
exist even in two-player zero-sum
non-convex games
there's a generalization generalization
of such local nash equilibrium known as
local approximate pure strategy nash
equilibrium
those do exist because they can be
phrased at the fixed point of a
continuous operator in a compact space
but unfortunately they're p-pad hard to
compute uh this is shown by dusk lockies
schoolofis and zambitakis
so
we're going to do something a little
different we're going to say well local
equilibria have these issues let's look
instead for global
mix dash equilibrium these are just
mixed nash equilibria of this infinite
game
and that's in the two player zero sum
game setting more generally in
multiplayer general sum settings we can
look for a global course correlated
equilibrium
of course when we do this there's going
to be an elephant in the room
uh global equilibrium non-convex
settings are going to be computationally
intractable even in a single agent
setting optimizing a non-convex function
is computationally intractable
so how do we deal with this
ultimately i think one strategy is to
try to define some oracle which has
efficient heuristics and practice
although those may not be provable
we want there to be an oracle efficient
algorithm for this oracle
this is not a question we address in our
current paper it's left for future work
and i'll discuss uh some directions
along these lines further at the end of
the talk
i think it's important to understand
the basic statistical questions before
moving on to the computational ones
okay so
learning in large infinite games how do
we do this well let's consider a
two-player zero-sum game with infinite
action spaces you can think of these as
for instance uh
the action space is the space of weights
of a neural network
there's a few questions we want to
consider
the first is whether nash equilibria
exists of course those local notions of
equilibrium i mentioned a couple of
slides ago may not exist
so if we're going to try to get around
these issues by considering a different
notion of equilibria
we should make sure it exists
second if nash equilibria do exist then
at what rates can we get convergence to
them
will in particular consider no regret
algorithms
now this question has actually mostly
been answered by priority in the
literature
for instance it was shown by rackland uh
sweetheart and tuareg
but under a particular compactness
assumption which guarantees the
existence of nash equilibrium
you can get an algorithm that achieves
essentially optimal rates
for
non-parametric classes against an
adversary
and the work more or less generalizes to
hold under any setting in which we can
show a mid-max theorem
but of course analogously to as i
discussed earlier in the talk
we're not really content with worst case
adversary regret and gains we want to
somehow use the fact that agents are
playing in games to get improved regret
balance
so typically these worst case regress
rounds will scale as the square root of
the time horizon when i say fast rates i
want something that's less than root t
okay so i'm now going to discuss our
answers to the first and third questions
on this line of course the second has
already been answered
the first question on the existence of
nash equilibrium games unfortunately has
a negative answer
nash equilibrium may not exist in
infinite gates
and if you've seen this result before
chances are you've seen a particular
counter example
known as guess the larger number
so here's the game it's a two-player
zero-sum game the action spaces
of each player the space of all natural
numbers and the rules of the game are
very simple
whoever guesses the larger number wins
let's break ties say in favor of the max
player
if you think about this for a couple
minutes uh you'll quickly see that
this infinite two-player zero sum game
has no approximate nash equilibrium even
up to a constant approximation
so nika talked about this in her
tutorial a few weeks ago so i won't go
into the proof
but it's a very simple proof uh you know
there's not there's really not much to
it
so this is somewhat disappointing we
want nash equilibrium to exist
but there is a glimmer of hope which is
that
probably none of you have seen any other
counter examples
there's a reason for that which was that
in a really nice result by hanukki livni
and iran last year
they showed that
basically this guess the larger number
game is the only obstacle to having a
nash equilibrium
in particular if an infinite binary game
is no sub game which is isomorphic to
guess the larger number
then this infinite binary game is
approximate nash equilibria
for any positive approximation
now this condition of not having any sub
games which would guess a larger number
is a very clean condition to state but
unfortunately it's not that operational
um
a slightly more convenient condition to
work with which is sufficient for this
sub game condition
is that those games with finite little
stone dimension have no sub game that's
guessed the larger number and therefore
have approximate nash equilibria
now for those who aren't familiar with
littles but i mentioned um i'll define
it in a couple of slides for now
but for now you can think of it as an
online learning analog of the vc
dimension the primary which
characterizes online variability
also note that having fun at least the
dimension is in a certain somewhat vague
sense almost necessary for not having
any sub games which are guessed a larger
number
the first result is we extend the result
by hanukki libya moran to the real value
setting
in particular what we show is that if an
infinite real valued game has no sub
game which is close to some affine
transform of just a larger number
then this game has epsilon approximately
not shake libya for all positive epsilon
and by half fine transform i simply mean
you take entries to get the larger
number you shift them you scale them by
positive constant and then you shift
them
okay so both of these theorems have
what's essentially a converse in
particular what hanukkah olivia moran
showed it and what we can show
is that
a necessary and sufficient condition for
a game in all its sub games to have nash
equilibria is that they don't contain
some copy or approximate copy of guess
the larger number
so that basically answers the question
of equilibrium existence so let's move
on to our second main question
which is that can we get fast rates for
learning in games and i'll focus on
games of finite little stone dimension
of course by the condition on the
previous slide for these games we're on
solid footing we know that nash
equilibria exists
so here's our main result we show that
there's a no regret learning algorithm
that if each player uses it then the
regret in games scales is t to the one
fourth times a polynomial in little
stone dimension and this holds even in
general some binary valued gates
this gets the fast rates that we wanted
um the important thing to note is that
it has no explicit dependence on the
number of actions unlike basically all
prior work getting fast rates for
learning in games
in particular the dependence number of
actions of the prior work is longer than
the number of actions
this results uh you know it can be
viewed as a sort of improvement upon
that because little stone dimension is
always bounded above by the logarithm of
the sides of the action space
of course there is you know one part of
this result which isn't that strong
which is the
polynomial dependence on t uh of course
in the finite game setting we can get
something down the poly logarithmic t
it's open as to whether or not that's
possible in the general sun beam setting
yeah
uh so
for a non-fat trait where would be
so the question is for for non-fast
rates like square root what was known
so you can get root little dimension
times t
okay
the payout
it's a measure of complexity
okay so um
as importantly
we get the expected results about
convergence to equilibria
in particular in two-player zero-sum
game setting we get convergence to
approximate nash equal libya and in
general some game settings we get
convergence of the joint action profiles
averages to coarse correlate equilibria
both at a rate of t to the minus
three-fourths
and this improves upon the rate of one
over root t that you get
from the adversarial setting
so now i'll discuss the proof of this
theorem
uh the proof is quite long um and
there's several ingredients in it
roughly speaking these are ingredients
really apply to the the more general
setting of adversarial online learning
the non-game setting
and i think several of them are of
independent interest so i'll try to give
an overview of the
ingredients that i think maybe you know
have applications in other settings as
well
um so first of all we get fast rates for
proper online learnings in the setting
of
online learning known as the realizable
setting i'll define what this is in a
moment
uh we show how to make our proper online
realizable learner stable
and finally we show how to use that
proper online stable learner to get a
path length regret bound in the
non-realizable setting
so i'll explain what all these things
mean
but first of all i need to define what
the littlest dimension of the game is
so
consider as before a binary value gain g
and the loss function of agent i is
denoted by li it's a function of the m
agent's actions
now these action spaces ai are
we're going to consider the setting now
where these are extremely large or
infinite
so unlike the first part of the talk
where we use the size of the action sets
to measure complexity we don't want to
do that anymore
we want some other measure of complexity
and the way we do this is as follows
we're going to define a bunch of
function classes otherwise known as
hypothesis classes associated with the
game there's one for each agent
and the hypothesis class for agent i
denoted by h.i
is this class of functions right here
it's indexed by actions ai of agent i
and for each such action ai there's a
function in the class h i which maps the
actions of all other agents to the loss
of agent i when they play according to
their actions a i and a minus sign
so this is a sort of induced hypothesis
class from the game
given by you know agent i's loss
function on uh all possible actions of
agent height
now we define the little dimension of
the game to be the maximum of the
littlest dimension of any of these
hypothesis classes h i
but of course i haven't told you what
the little dimension of hypothesis
classes
so in general for class hive hypotheses
mapping from the space of joint actions
of other agents to zero one
uh there's a
complexity measure of it uh
corresponding uh
known as little
dimension and to define what this is i'm
now going to move away from the game
setting to the setting of adversarial
online learning so there's a little bit
of a context switch here we're now going
to be talking about the adversarial
setting
in the adversarial setting i'm going to
actually
generalize notation a little bit i'll
fix a space x
so in the game setting this would be a
minus i
also fix a hypothesis class big h of
hypotheses h which map from x to zero
one these are binary hypotheses on x
and we consider the setting of
adversarial online classification
so at each time step little t from one
to capital t uh we have the following
scenario
the learner chooses a hypothesis h t
mapping from the space x to zero one
this hypothesis h t need not lie in the
class big h
the adversary chooses a pair x t y t
consisting of
the points in the space x as well as a
binary label
after choosing them the learner and the
adversary reveal their choices to each
other
and the learner suffers a loss which is
the difference between hd of xt and yt
this loss is one if the learner
incorrectly predicts the label of y t
given x t and it's zero if the learner's
prediction is correct
now there's a constraint that we're
going to place in the adversary which is
known as the realizable setting
in particular we constrain the adversary
to choose their examples x to y t
so that they're all consistent with some
hypothesis h star belonging to the class
big h
in a realizable setting the definition
of regret collapses to
what's known as cumulative loss or a
mistake bound which is simply the sum
over all time steps of the loss of the
learner this is because that comparative
term the definition of regret
is zero
the lewiston dimensional hypothesis
class is the smallest positive integer d
so there exists an algorithm whose
mistake down or cumulative loss bound is
at most d and this holds against any
realizable adversary
so some of you may have seen middleton
dimension defined in a different way
namely is the depth of the largest tree
which is shattered by the hypothesis
class this definition is equivalent
and that was basically the main you know
one of the most well-known results of
little stone's paper
back in the 80s
this definition this algorithmic
definition is a little more convenient
for the purposes of this talk
and in particular
i'm now going to discuss our first main
ingredient of the proof
which can be seen as
correcting a certain issue with the
setup of learning i had on the previous
slide
so in the next few slides i'll kind of
have a little box in the upper
right-hand corner which reminds you of
the choices the learner and adversary
make at each iteration
recall in the previous slide that the
choices ht of the learner did not have
to lie in the hypothesis class big h
in other words such algorithms are known
as improper learning algorithms
a proper learning algorithm in contrast
is one that requires that ht belongs to
h
perhaps surprisingly in many settings
proper learning is strictly harder than
improper learning
this holds both in a computational sense
and also in a statistical sense and for
various problems in fact there are
problems that proper learners cannot
solve but that improper learners can
solve
unfortunately we actually need proper
learning algorithms for applications and
gains
this holds roughly because proper
learning algorithms are those which
choose roughly speaking valid actions
here's our main here's our here's one of
our results
we show that there's a randomized proper
learning algorithm that achieves a
cumulative loss bound which scales as
this quantity shown here against any
realizable adversary
so we called it for improper learning
algorithms in the previous slide the the
loss bound the mistake bound was just
middle school dimension
uh the amount here we get a bound which
is a little bit worse it's off by a
logarithmic factor a poly logarithmic
factor the time horizon
it's an interesting question to see if
you can get this all the way down to the
little dimension but really it kind of
gets it's it's the fast it's the first
result that
that gets fast rates
for proper learning against the
realizable adversary
in particular the best on regret bound
prior to this
was on this order of the square root of
littlest dimension times t
so it's the first you know it basically
improves routine down to poly log t
yep
okay so
you should have like
[Music]
the
treatment right
right so that's in the game setting like
that's not realizable i mean so there's
a disc joint settings
ah it's not really right
okay
yeah so the the questions about the the
previous results
the game setting so that's not
realizable and i'll discuss how we use
the brook's results and realizability to
get results to the non-realizable
setting in a couple of slides but but
this is this is a different setting in
the game
[Music]
doesn't necessarily exist in optimal
uh hypothesis in your class the
character that classifies all the
examples correctly
now one other thing i'll mention is that
randomization is actually necessary to
get a sublinary graph bound um for for
proper learning um so we can't make this
thing deterministic
but we also have an extension of this
theorem to the real value setting
finally i'll note that the technique is
is fairly complicated the algorithm is
somewhat complex but it follows this
framework of hanukki livniyamaran
it's kind of an explicit constructive
algorithm in a certain sense
okay so moving on from uh from proper
learning there's one additional
constraint that we need to place on our
proper learner which is known as
stability
so i define a proper learner to be
stated a stable data stable for some
positive real number eta
if the consecutive hypotheses the proper
learner outputs
ht and ht plus one are distributed
according to distributions that have
total variation distance at most ada so
informally this is just saying that the
outputs the proper learning algorithm
don't change much from round to round
we can actually show an extension of our
result on the previous slide to get a
data stable proper learning algorithm
in particular for any data there's such
an algorithm that gets a mistake bound
at most one over eta times the loss
bound from the previous slide and this
holds against any realizable adversary
so how do you get an agent stable proper
order
it's actually very easy
you just take the learner from the
previous slide and you average
the last eight one over eight of
consecutive hypotheses at outputs
this is immediately
you seem to be a to stable because
you're only changing mass eta from
iteration to iteration
the more challenging part is to get this
loss bound and you know it seems very
natural to get the scaling of one over
theta but it's actually not immediate it
doesn't work in general
in fact if you're not careful about
averaging
you might get a cumulative loss uh
linear in t
and so in order to get this bound it's
very much sublinear at least for
reasonably sized data we have to do a
very careful analysis of the explicit
construction of the proper learner i had
on the previous slide
i think this this result may have some
independent applications um
uh stability and learning has been
studied in many other settings as well
okay so finally i'll move on to the
final intermediate result we need to get
for our result on fast rates and games
um
i'm now going to move beyond the
realizable setting to the non-realizable
setting
and we call it a normalizable setting
the aim is to minimize regret as opposed
to cumulative loss
and
what we show is the following
there's a randomized proper learning
algorithm which is also stable i'm now
setting the stability parameter to t to
the minus one fourth
and this satisfies the following
if for all time steps t the adversary
chooses examples x t and x c plus one
which are close to each other in a
certain sense i won't define formally
here
then the regret of the algorithm is t to
the one fourth times a polynomial in
little dimension so this is exactly the
sort of fast rates that i claim in gains
but it's under this
condition which is not realizability but
it's a certain closeness of the
adversary's
examples now the proof of this result
actually uses the proper stable learner
from the previous slide
it's a relatively standard technique and
here's how it goes roughly speaking
we're going to construct what's known as
a sequential cover of the hypothesis
which consists of proper stable
realizable learners and we're going to
use elements of this sequential cover
which for now you can just think of as
different algorithms
different online learning algorithms
we're going to use them as experts and
plug that into optimistic hedge
i won't go into detail into what this
means so much but i'm just going to say
that optimistic hedge gives us a fairly
generic way of getting fast rates
as long as these experts these
individual algorithms don't change much
from around iteration to iteration
and this is exactly why we need
stability it's to get this this it's
basically be able to plug an optimistic
hedge which then spits out fast rates
for us
okay so
so what this means is that you know once
we've proven this theorem
all we have to do in order to get fast
rates in the game setting is to show
that from each agent's perspective
the effective adversary given by all
other agents
actions in each time step leads to
examples that are close to each other up
to this approximation of t to the minus
one
this actually holds quite immediately in
the game setting again by the stability
property
of this proper randomized proper
learning algorithm
and so this is the second place in
instability stability is really crucial
uh in the proof of the proof of this
result
and that's how we get fast rates in
games um basically it's immediate
corollary of this pathway that we that
so i'll finally
conclude
there's a lot of different notions of
equal libya out there in the literature
in the
setting of generic non-convex games
on the one hand there are these notions
of equal libya which are local in nature
that i discussed earlier on
namely pure strategy local approximate
national peer strategy local match
unfortunately they're either
computationally hard or
do not exist sometimes respectively
now the results of our work can be seen
as
lying on the opposite end in this local
global spectrum
looking at global equilibria and as we
show following prior work they do exist
and actually we can get fast rates for
convergence to them
now these rates are statistical nature
algorithm is not computationally
efficient in any way
oracle efficiency um is a really
interesting open question
unfortunately there are some negative
results in the literature on oracle
efficiency so hasan and kren show oracle
lower bounds for computing uh nash
equilibria even in two-player zero some
games
with an erm or empirical risk
minimization oracle
this is fairly disappointing it
basically tells us that you can't get
efficient oracle efficiency with respect
to this oracle
but there may be some extensions of this
oracle for which you can get oracle
efficiency or there may be additional
assumptions that you can place beyond
worst case assumptions you can place on
your game
once again in order to surpass these
oracle lower bounds
so that's one interesting direction
another is to kind of explore this space
in the middle between local and global
so there actually are some positive
results in this in the literature in
fact a few of them i think are going to
be discussed later on in this workshop
and some of these notions of equilibrium
can be seen as
somehow being mostly local nature but
having some maybe global aspect to it
and and i think kind of this middle
ground finding stronger middle ground
notions of equilibria could also satisfy
some sort of computational for oracle
efficiency is a really interesting
direction for future work
that's it thank you for listening
are there any questions
the algorithm where you also take into
account around t minus one like uh does
it help if you look at a few further
rounds in the past like you get better
do you reduce the exponent or you cannot
basically yeah there's a good question
you're talking about optimistic hedges
the first part yeah yeah uh so that
actually doesn't help at least like if
you do it kind of in the
natural way where you just say
um i mean i don't know what weights they
should have right so like i don't think
that's been fully explored um and
there's like a kind of a general class
of algorithms you can study like this
um
people there have been some papers which
look at like
what happens if you do it in a
particular way with certain weights
and they show that you actually don't
get any battery grab rounds in fact they
actually get a little bit worse
um like the more rounds you go back you
get the your we get back gets worse by
like a constant factor or something
so this is for a specific choice of
weights or for it's very specific choice
of weights
um in terms of general choices of
weights uh
maybe you can improve your graph
boundary like by a constant factor like
in many like optimistic edge basically
gets
optimistic gradient descent descent in
general gets optimal rates for for you
know
those
not convex concave problems we're aware
of
uh so like i don't think you'd be able
to
improve it by more than a constant
factor by lower bounds
but i think it's possible that maybe
there's constant factor improvements you
can get by
i thought there was a
gap between the lower bond and the upper
bound you mean for
our fast rates like the long t the
volume t
yeah so that's that's possible um
i think that probably i mean this is
just a guess but i think that probably
optimistic hedge will get the best like
i don't think you'll need to look back
further but it's it's possible it will
um it's a good question
no you mentioned that if the algorithm
has lassiter convergence it helps you in
the proof
to get like faster you know like smaller
regret
like can you make this claim formal
uh no
i mean i i think it's it's more like so
the particular paper by psy
at all that i was thinking of
um
they they they have several lemons which
i think they're both used for lasting
convergence
and this fast rates
um
it actually would be interesting to make
it formal because that would be a really
nice application of last of the
convergence
um but i think for now it's just that
informal sense
okay thanks
so
in terms of like contextualizing the
literature
why don't these algorithms or the
results follow from like sequential or
the market complexity notions or do they
follow along this paradigm or where does
it stop like uh
yeah that's a great question so um in
terms some of them like i think do it's
like getting the fast rates in the
realizable setting um i think you can
use sequential automatic effects to get
those
the place where like as far as i can
tell you cannot expense a bunch of
automatic complexity is to get this
stability property basically in a
learning algorithm it only changes by a
little bit from round to round
um that's where basically the minimax
theory that you use for this bunch of
automatic complexities
doesn't seem to work
um and that's where we need this
explicit construction
so i think it'd be really interesting to
kind of use that machinery to get these
results as well
um but you know
we try it and it doesn't seem to work
all right let's thank no again
[Applause]
and
we're back at 2 p.m
for the afternoon session and the
reception